optimal at this altitude I can run flat
out for a half mile before my hands
start shaking and oil is your personal
question now it is
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton this episode is
brought to you by 99designs whether you
need a logo custom website app book
cover or anything else 99 designs was
created to make great design accessible
to everyone that's you and to make the
process as easy as possible I've used 99
designs for years now I've used them for
book covers some mock-ups for the 4-hour
body which went on to become a number
one York Times bestseller illustrations
of all different types for the
multi-volume The Tao of Seneca which you
can check out and other graphic design
projects for a long time now and I've
been very impressed by the quality of
their designers and illustrators and you
don't have to take my word for it you
should check out some of my projects at
99designs com forward slash Tim I really
encourage you to take a look because you
will be impressed 99designs com forward
slash Tim 9 and Designs has freelance
experts in more than 90 design
categories in their platform lets you
work directly with one designer that you
choose if you like their stuff which is
what I did for the town of Seneca or you
can get concepts from multiple designers
and then pick your favorite so whether
you're starting a business or just
looking for extra design help resources
etc 99designs has a solution right now
you guys my listeners can receive a free
$99 upgrade on your first design to
check out your first free upgrade please
visit 99 designs comm forward slash Tim
and click the link on the landing page
you can also find their samples of
projects from you guys
listeners who have used nine and designs
for logos apps even product packaging so
check it out 99 designs com forward
slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by
wordpress.com
I love WordPress I have used it for so
many years it's my go-to platform for
blogging and creating websites I use
wordpress.com for everything every day
my site Tim not blog is built on it the
websites for my books including tools of
titans tribe of mentors it's all on
wordpress.com and the founder matt
mullenweg
when my close friends has appeared on
this show many times
just search matt mullenweg tequila
Ferriss for quite an exciting time
whether you're looking to create a
personal blog a business site or both
you can make a really big impact right
out of the box when you build on
wordpress.com and you'll be in good
company it's used by the New Yorker
jay-z Beyonce 5:38 TechCrunch Ted CNN
and time just to name a handful and one
of my friends at Google she'll remain
nameless has told me that wordpress.com
offers the quote best out-of-the-box SEO
imaginable end quote and it's one of the
many reasons that nearly 30% of the
Internet is run on WordPress you do not
need experience or to hire someone
that's perhaps the best part
wordpress.com guides you through the
entire experience they have hundreds of
designs and templates that you can use
and it's easy to get started there's no
need to worry about security upgrades
hosting any of that they offer 24/7
support and they're very very responsive
if you have questions they get right
back to you and this allows you to
create the highest quality with the
least amount of headache and friction so
if you're building a website period when
my friends come to me and ask what I use
what I recommend they use the answer is
wordpress.com so check it out if you
want to get started today learn more
with a 15% discount off any new plan go
to wordpress.com forward slash Tim to
create your website and find the plan
that's right for you
to learn more take a look wordpress.com
forward slash Tim for a 15% off a brand
new website check it out
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show where it is my job to
deconstruct world class performers
people who are exceptionally good at
what they do to tease out the routines
have its favorite books and so on that
you can hopefully test and apply to your
own lives and my guest today is none
other than drew Houston H oh you sto n
at drew Houston on Twitter and elsewhere
he's the co-founder and CEO of Dropbox
since founding the company in 2007 with
Arash Ferdowsi Drew has led the
company's growth from a simple idea to a
service used by 500 million people
around the world you can let that number
sink in drew received his bachelor's
degree in electrical engineering and
computer science from MIT in 2006 I
think I've heard of that place after
graduating he turned his frustration
with carrying USB drives and emailing
files to himself into a demo for what
then became Dropbox today Dropbox is one
of the world's leading business
collaboration platforms with 11 million
paying subscribers and 18 hundred plus
employees across 12 global offices drew
welcome to the show
thank you you know I've wanted to have
an excuse to ask you for your life story
and all these details because we've
known each other quite a while but it's
super weird to sit down with a glass of
wine at a dinner table or something like
that and just start asking you for your
dr. evil story so this is this is a fun
opportunity for me to dig in so I
appreciate you taking the time
awesome yeah me too it's it's it's great
to be here and I thought we would start
with some of the back story that I do
not know and that is your childhood and
perhaps you could just begin by telling
us how you would describe yourself as a
kid I mean let's just call it kind of
three to sixth grade or anytime really
what type of kid were you so yeah going
way back well I first I was I was
definitely that kid who was on computers
so we my parents I remembered just like
like toddling into my living room and
seeing this glowing orb and all these
buttons and those were two things I
really liked when I was three I guess
still do so for sure I was I was super
interested in computers and technology
and started out by by playing computer
or video games basically that was like
the first interest and then I wanted to
make my own computer games I thought
that my career was going to be starting
a computer game company and I thought
that was that there would be nothing
better than that
and so I bought out but I was that kid I
learned programming at an early age I
grew up in just outside of Boston so I
grew up in New England and and then on
my way to MIT I really liked math
science so kind of out of central
casting in terms of being a computer
science student and then yeah and then
then I got my first career was
babysitting but then I discovered that
you could be paid to program and then
that caused a bit of a career shift
which we can talk about as much as I
enjoyed the babysitting lifestyle you
get like three bucks an hour I eat some
Pringles watch some HBO it's not that
bad but uh but programming was even
better anyway so so so but in in middle
school and in high school I ended up
getting a bunch of programming
internships or summer jobs at what were
Star Abed startups basically one of the
most remote most of them are local but
then that got me on a path of starting
companies and being involved in startups
but I would say those are probably the
the biggest when it when it when it
comes to Dropbox and everything that
kind of followed after from my childhood
it was a happy childhood lots of it was
still pretty balanced but I did I've
liked programming and engineering
for sure my first my first love and were
you a shy kid and extroverted kid played
sports kind of kept to yourself at
recess what was what would somebody
looking in from the outside like how
would your how would your third grade
teacher describe you in that capacity
yeah I think somewhere the middle so I
wasn't reclusive I had a really great
group of friends
I wasn't captain of the soccer team
either I think I did I did academic I
did academic decathlon which is just a
fascinating thing that it exists but you
know more of a mess Leeds than an
athlete athlete's so but and I was I was
not like a super social but I had a good
group of friends and and then for sure
as I went into college I became a lot
more social and and and just curious
about humans and human behavior but uh
but otherwise I think people like that I
would have been known in class as always
doing earlier that I think they were
like those superlatives and yearbooks I
think I was like most likely to start a
company or a piece they pegged it pretty
early yeah so I was doing a homework for
this which I always enjoy doing when
it's it's someone I know because I dig
up all these bits and pieces that I then
want to ferret out and explore a bit so
I I came across this line that described
folding chair on top of fraternity at
MIT and that you would go up there with
piles of books and read these books so I
did you place us when that was in your
undergrad career and how you chose the
books and why you did that yeah so I it
was about my junior year of of undergrad
I took a leave of absence because I had
an idea for a startup that I wanted to
pursue so I took a year off to do that
what I noticed was that the this was
back in 2004 so the I was maybe 21 and
the SAT was changing or I start an
online SAT prep company and maybe even
because what the opportunity was was the
SAT was changing in 2004-2005 from 1600
points to 2400 points so suddenly all
the course material overnight was gonna
be obsolete and so I saw an opportunity
to maybe develop not just a course for
the new SAT but an online course and I
teamed up with a former teacher from my
high school who had his own little
cottage SAT prep company and I'm like
hey if we come together we can put this
thing online and we'll be on an even
playing field because you know all those
800 page books that have been printed
about it are now obsolete and who really
wants to go to some classroom at 8:00 in
the morning on Saturday anyway like we
can build a much better experience if we
do it online so I was really excited
about starting a company and we jumped
into it and I think we met in a Chili's
and like we're planning world domination
and like figuring out how do you
incorporate a company and says a really
great introduction to the world of
starting companies and then it was it
also the more I learned about the
mechanics of starting company the more I
realized I didn't know about business
and I knew a lot about engineering and
programming and I'd been I'd worked at
startups but when it came to when it was
kind of that there was a fog beyond just
like building the product and so I got
we're gonna need I know like sales and
marketing and and strategy like these
are all things and all I know is I don't
know a lot about them so I had the
highly scientific method of I just was
like all right I'm just gonna go on
Amazon type in sales by the top three or
four books and just do that for every
like category and then I had a couple
book recommendations from one of the
founders of one of the companies where I
worked as well but but it was great and
it was it
there's an important combination so if
one was one was actually starting the
company gaming motivation to really
learn the stuff because I think a lot of
times when you're reading it can just be
like entertainment basically it's like
something where you just like read the
book you're like that's interesting but
then don't use the knowledge right but
we're actually starting a company then
you really have an excuse to internalize
and really study the material so there's
a big difference between reading the
material and studying it don't know but
I was pretty systematic about it I'm
like okay here's all the stuff that I
don't know and and then reading is gonna
be a good way to get me introduced to
all these topics and all of that maybe
the first instance of that was when you
know I went through my high school and I
was and there are a lot of great books
that you read as part of your you know
high school curriculum but then I
stumbled across the book emotional
intelligence by Daniel Goleman and I was
like oh my god like this is just like
it's nonfiction but it's it spelled out
something that was I just didn't know
you could kind of break down in a
logical way and suddenly I have this
understanding about the world that I
didn't have before and so that was
important because it sort of it was sort
of one of a bunch of early examples that
anything is trainable and
and it got me out a path to developing
what we now call a growth mindset and
realizing that's possible to learn about
these things that you that were where
you have no experience or where it's
easy to be like oh I don't know about
that or I'm just an engineer I'm not a
business person and kind of shatter that
misconception do you think that you were
open to all these different categories
of learning because of the necessity
visa vie starting the company the reason
I ask that is that it's it's not across
the board but some people with
engineering chops have seemed to have a
learned or intrinsic disdain for sales
marketing these different bits and
pieces of businesses that are a little
softer let's say less quantifiable
in some respects was it was it simply
the motivation in building this company
where you had to write or rather wear
all those hats that kind of drove you
into these different categories or were
you intrinsically using that word quite
a bit but interested in learning more
about these different buckets through
these different books well I think it's
a little of both
so certainly starting the company made
it a necessity and created a lot a lot
of additional motivation but the
experience I also found these other
topics just as interesting as the
engineering and I and I think it's yes a
big culture when engineers start off by
being dismissive or defensive about that
the technology is all that matters or if
it doesn't have a triple integral and
Greek letters it doesn't count a certain
thing like a cultural meme at MIT and I
think it just creates a huge blind spot
for people both because it makes it less
effective but it's also like the stuff
is it is actually really interesting and
but I kept having experiences like that
and the emotional intelligence was just
one example but I took a class on
negotiation at MIT which sort of opened
my eyes a notch further on this kind of
thing where I'm like alright negotiation
I go into that class I don't know a lot
about it I'm like whoever like yells
louder lies more smacks the table harder
I guess that's what makes you a good
negotiator and then this class like I
mean those those are tactics but like
the class has these frameworks we're
like okay so more people have thought
about this and they've broken it down
and you and it turns out that there's a
whole process of uncovering mutual
interests and figuring out what your
leverage is and your best alternative
data and so and spelling it out in a way
where I was like actually this is a lot
more straightforward than some of the
theoretical math classes I'm I have to
take and it's a lot more applicable to
my daily life and so I started to I
really appreciated like learning a
little bit about a lot of different
disciplines and and just putting up a
folding chair on my roof was the first
thing that came to mind is
far as how I could actually do that were
there any other books
besides emotional intelligence during
that period that really had an impact on
you yes in that negotiation class is a
book called getting to yes which is
about principled negotiation and I still
think about a lot of those I still think
about and apply a lot of those concepts
today and then some of the so part of it
was just like kind of doing a random
walk on Amazon but I also became friends
with the founders of the companies where
I worked and I went during lunch breaks
or another time but I go like chase him
down and bug them and ask some questions
about like hey how do you start a
company like to have any book
recommendations just making that it's
kind of taking advantage of being the
bright-eyed bushy-tailed intern and
shaking down my boss or my mentor or my
founder or my mentors for advice and so
two of the books that were really
instrumental though the first one was
innovators dilemma by clay Christensen
it's a book about how businesses get
disrupted and and what in it's a big
plot of those themes or why startups can
succeed and thrive even when there are
big competitors who you would think
would just wipe them out and so how that
cycle works and there's a book called
crossing the chasm which is another
classic yeah it's a book on marketing
technology marketing it's like how do
how do you how do technology products
make their way from early adopters to
the mainstream and if you found yourself
revisiting those books or were they a
point in time during that rooftop Amazon
education period I have I met I'd say
there are a lot of you read a lot of
books not all of them are as good as the
innovators dilemma but then yeah it also
helps to revisit some of the classics
innovators dilemmas actually both those
books are good examples so so yeah I do
revisit them because again one to twenty
one and you've never had a real job you
know you're reading this book and you
sort of get a general sense for things
but you don't you don't really deeply
understand the con
steps and then coming back five years
later ten years later you can really
absorb a lot more of the material so I I
do I I read a lot of books in general
and then when I'm reading a book
I'll triage I'm like okay is it
something I need to study is it
something that's like interesting or is
it that I might need to know something
about or is it just fun and if you study
it if I'm like I need to study this book
then I approach it pretty differently
than if it's just like entertainment and
for those people who haven't read
getting to yes
when you were leading into that with
some of the concepts from the class I
thought to myself I bet that was part of
the class or one of the books you read
because you had best alternative and
there's a term I do recommend also
people read getting to yes Batna best at
turn ative to negotiated agreement which
is a really important concept to grasp
and there's another book that I might
recommend to people I think it was
written later by one of the co-authors
of getting to yes called getting past no
I think they go together really really
nicely if you were teaching say and
we're just gonna stick on books for a
little bit because I know you varied so
much if you were teaching saying a
freshman class or senior class undergrad
- let's just say smart but non-technical
people and you were assigning books to
read and they could be part of the class
or things that could be read in advance
if you were to pick I'm just pulling
this out of thin air but three to five
books that would be sort of the core of
your reading list I do any come to mind
that we that we haven't talked about
yeah so for this for the sake of
starting Earth if the subject of the
class we're starting a company yeah or
evolving from being an engineer to being
a business person I have a few I have a
handful of books that I really love and
it's like concepts I still that I use
and think about every day so
probably my two favorites are high
output management by Andy Grove which
Andy Grove was the CEO of Intel which
was kind of the Google of its time back
in the particularly back in the 80s and
early 90s so he Andy was an engineer one
of the founding engineers and then rose
the ranks at Intel and became CEO so
he's lived this path and and when I read
about or I heard about this book and it
was introduced me as the best book on
management ever written and I agree and
it just breaks down all the mechanics of
ok how do you run a team how do you
break down a goal into into sub-goals
how do you just that the 101 of running
a team and running an organization and a
focus on output and results and how do
you measure people and just love things
that you nuts and bolts things that you
challenges that you encounter when
you're when you're running a team
whether that's a company or a team
within a company the second is the
effective executive which does a great
by Peter Drucker
and the central core of that book is
really about if the people it's very
easy to mistake effort for effectiveness
there are a lot of different phrases for
this like and to confuse motion for
progress or but but it's really about
that idea so how do you how do you know
if you're being effective what practices
and there's a bunch of practices that
you can adopt that that make you more
effective and then how to avoid the sand
traps of things that feel productive but
aren't actually and how do you date sex
or how do you unpack the case where we
all have the same number of hours in a
day but some of us seem to accomplish a
lot more than others why is that and
what can you do instead so the effective
executive is it covers a lot of that
ground that that's enough that those two
I think of as kind of like textbooks
like you want to study them you want to
take notes you want to really chew on
the material then I I think there's
others there there's a lot of other
tactical
is about starting a company I'd say some
more of the a favorite book that's more
about the experience of running a
company is ben horowitz his book hard
thing about hard things right which is
kind of just shows you kind of a mess
and adventure and the crazy highs and
lows of and like what the human
experience is of actually having to do
this and then I probably doom out and
get a little more philosophical so a
couple favorite books are poor Charlie's
Almanac by Charlie Munger so Charlie
Munger is Warren Buffett's longtime
business partner and and one of the this
book is really interesting because one
of the things about being a CEO or
taking on big responsibility for
anything is you have to make a lot of
decisions about a lot of different
things and do it quickly and be right
and so how do you be right about tons of
different things especially you don't
have a lot of life experience like how
do you train up that skill quickly I
mean that's really called wisdom or
judgment and so the so it's like how do
you how do you grow wisdom or grow
judgment quickly poor Charlie's Almanac
is a great example of book so talks
about how actually a lot of what you
need to know to be successful in life
conceptually you learn it in middle
school or in high school you just don't
apply it or you don't really internalize
the concepts and he argues that a lot of
really wise and effective people develop
or they basically build a catalog of
mental models where and concepts whether
that's something from and basically
assemble all the best ideas from all the
different disciplines and then figure
out how do you apply them in life and so
for example the concept of a Batna like
in leverage that that might be a concept
that can be applied in all kinds of
different situations or comparative
advantage from economics or a
or you could you could go on about these
different concepts but then figuring out
how do you internalize them so well that
you're able to figure out okay these are
what matters in these situations and
then and then how do you avoid petty
particularly avoid terrible decisions
but really how do you build enough again
enough of these he calls it a
latticework how do you build enough of a
network of these mental models so that
you know which ones to apply when and
that you find yourself most of time
being able to make good quick decisions
and then also on the philosophical front
so zen and the art of motorcycle
maintenance yeah peer sig yeah so you
talked about engineers who like dismiss
clique all these things that can't be
fit and do an algorithm or or you know
that don't have to have some kind of
like mathematical rigor rigor
underpinning them
zen and the art of motorcycle
maintenance is about that like just that
question okay you have like this whole
rational world which can explain a bunch
of stuff but then you have the whole
aesthetic world which can't be boiled
down to a formula and they both exist
and they are both useful in different
cases but they don't tend to get along
and so how do you like so what's up with
that and then it's a really great book
about those kind of concepts and I think
developing an appreciation for for both
or developing both your left and right
brain you know to to to use that analogy
I think is really important if you're if
you're running a team or or growing a
company because there's a lot of stuff
for it's a lot about technique and data
and and in sort of like and a lot of
things like strategy or the engineering
how are kind of fall into these if this
and that kind of reasoning but then a
lot of the hard part of the job is
really about people and and what
motivates people how do you paint a
vision of the world that's exciting for
people how do you build good
relationships how do you develop
products with taste those are things
that are not going to be where you're
not able to reach as much into the
to the more rational or like kind of
engineering bag of tricks so I think
developing both of those developing both
sides your brain or developing an
appreciation for for both is really
valuable maybe one more the so
principles by by Ray Dalio who was I
know it was a recent guest
I think he's got really concise and good
thoughts for like alright how do you
sort of approach all the how do you
approach life so it's um I would include
a mix of different kind of things I'd
have like more instructional books like
more philosophical books more story and
history kind of books man I want to take
your class yes that's pretty good number
one so could consider me pre-registered
or free pre-applied I want to make a
couple of comments on these books that
you mentioned because I I am very fond
of all of these books and I was add of a
couple of notes because they tie
together also really nicely so high
output management by grove was out of
print at one point and then became so
popular in Silicon Valley that a new
edition was printed and the foreword I
believe was from Ben Horowitz who wrote
the another book that you had mentioned
you know the what is it the hard thing
about hard things right and Ben Horowitz
of andreessen horowitz and many other
things prior to that the said that book
and there's of course a selection bias
here since I have a limited data set but
the startups that I've been involved
with that have done best have kind of
returned the fund many many many times
over almost without exception have all
read high output management and have a
copy of it in their offices that's now
I'm sure there are many unsuccessful
CEOs who also have that book but
nonetheless the effective executive
actually going to leave that one for
last
so part Charlie's Almanac is a great
book and I want to underscore something
that you said somewhat in passing or
which is really important
and I know you know it's really
important which is the avoiding of
making really bad mistakes and one thing
that monger emphasizes a lot you know
the right hand of Warren Buffett and
more above it I guess to said he has the
fat the best 60 second mind he's ever
met and I'm gonna butcher this I'm sure
but it's something that I think of a lot
because I have some tendencies that are
unhelpful in in trying to be really
smart and come up with clever solutions
and I revisit this quote somebody could
find the right version but it's Munger
who says you know it's amazing how
successful you can become if you just
consistently avoid being stupid first is
trying to outsmart everybody else and I
think a lot about that because it's so
true it's like god yeah if you just kind
of watch your chips and know your
downside and don't make you know
consistently make rational decisions
with these lattice works and these
heuristics that you mentioned super
super helpful and the effective
executive so the effective executive I
want to come back to you for a second
and you mentioned nuts and bolts the
effective executive I've read probably
10 or 12 times I love this book and it's
it's very short - it's easy to read and
you mentioned the sort of nuts and bolts
so I'm gonna use this and then we'll
probably jump around chronologically but
you if I'm remembering correctly have a
label in your email called OPP could you
explain for people what this means yes
so original I I think originally well
yeah it was it stood for other people's
problems although I made it a little
nicer later other people's priorities
and because I have a vendetta against
email which we can we can we can dig
into but I I've had this experience
imagine anyone listening has had this
experience like alright your inbox is
over
you're like I'm finally gonna deal with
this thing you plow through hundreds of
emails and your reward is more emails
right but but then to the OPP thing I'm
like wait then what are these things
like what am i doing and then you
realize that like you're just basically
checking off items on other people's
to-do lists mm-hmm
where there's there's you know I sort of
in the abstract there's nothing wrong
with that and it's important to be
helpful and we all are have been helped
by and help other people but you can end
up in a situation where you're basically
your to-do list is a composite of other
people's to-do lists and in your
calendar and your email can often
reflect that and I and tying it to
another so one of the most important
concepts is focus everybody understands
like yeah yeah focus and I imagine
something we'll probably talk more about
here but that there are so many forces
it people love the idea of focus and and
and when it was interesting just going
back to Warren Buffett so Warren Buffett
and Bill Gates did in an interview it's
on I think it's on Netflix cuz I got a
Warren Buffett documentary which is
great
I also recommend but anyway they they
the interviewer was interviewing both
Warren and Bill and most like alright in
a word what is maybe most successful and
they both at the same time like without
missing a beat
both said focus and so if we all and
it's like seems so obvious we all know
why focus is is like we don't need to be
told why focus is important but then and
one of the things that the effective
executive highlights is there's so many
like the default for pretty much
anything is to unfocus you and that's
true of your inbox your inbox will just
is not prioritized it's just kind of
like you basically all these requests
that are other people's priorities if
you're working within an organization
pretty much everybody will be pulling on
you to kind of feed the beast of the
organization and so it becomes very hard
to do a few things well and so I mean
there's a lot of great things about that
but but yeah I do have an opp folder
which I try to keep manageable or find
ways to I think that best is if you can
find ways to be helpful button like and
involve other people and actually
helping so and I have a whole team of
people who can help me respond to those
those kinds of requests so know the OPP
folder it's not this it's not
necessarily a black hole it's not an
indefinite archive necessarily but it's
when I'll get around to it do you have a
set schedule for looking in the OPP
folder having other people do that for
you and what are the criteria right if
is it that anything that doesn't come
from say a direct report or an investor
or a family member goes into OPP or what
is like what are the guidelines
yeah so the I think some people would
say feel call even when I'm when I help
so I'm not great at responding to these
things so it might be if it's something
that's like not a priority then I'll try
to respond in days but sometimes this
week sometimes it's months sometimes
sometimes I'll get a response that's
like oh yeah it's seven months later
it's like I hear is you still need this
but so I would I think it's if it is
something from a person you have a
relationship with I would say you and
there's probably other factors but it's
like okay is this someone who I know and
where I where I personally would be
really helpful and they have done their
homework and it's like a link there's a
certain first pass filters like that I
would say that there is no commandment
from God that you have to respond to
every email you receive so that if it's
like a cold email cold car if it's like
some someone I don't know or it's like a
sales thing or whatever
I just then it just goes in the black
hole or if it's something like you know
there's a lot of folks who are like hey
I need I need a mentor or how do I raise
money or you can often tell by the
question like as a person many if not
most of
we'll be something where the person
could just do a little bit of homework
and get a good answer
and that's troubling because at first
you try to help people with those kinds
of things you're like oh well you know
go to this blog post or do this thing
and then you don't hear back from them
and it turns out they just never
followed up or just didn't do it and so
after you get burned by spending a bunch
of time trying to be helpful to people
who don't do their homework who don't
help themselves you realize that's like
not how you want to spend your life so
so you have to you know I don't think
there's a magic formula but but I think
you want to just keep what you want to
do just keep that budget of your time
constrained to something small yeah or
at least over smaller bit you should
just at least be mindful of it a lot of
people just and find themselves
hopelessly busy and on this treadmill
responding to other people's to-do lists
and knowing no one is doing the things
on their to-do list right yeah what can
you said about people doing their
homework reminded me of this quote from
Maria Popova who writes brain pickings
which is this incredible site millions
and millions of readers and really long
form smart writing and at some time I
think she changed it to be a little more
maybe sunny seeming but she had a quote
I'm pretty sure on her Facebook page as
the graphic as the header at one point
had said if you haven't done or if
someone hasn't done the homework to
determine whether it's a fit or not it
doesn't warrant the energy to explain
why it isn't a fit or something like
this which i think is a great
commandment or sort of guideline to use
because so much of it when you reinforce
that type of behavior by trying to be
helpful they just come back people tend
to come back with equally nebulous or
unthought through your questions do you
have any other best practices or dues or
do nots when it comes to to managing
email yes we're not using email yeah I
try not to use a lot of email
because often if it's I think emails for
is good for quick discreet tasks where
you're holding someone up by not doing
them but if you're trying to and then I
think it's also useful to like for
broadcast like if you have something if
you have some long-form written
direction that you want to give a group
of people then then it then that's a
good use of it but often when people get
into these long email threads it's often
I mean so it's sometimes be fun and
indulgent to get into these big like
flame wars but often the best way to if
you get a long email often the best
response is to talk to them in person
and if you're getting a lot of little
requests it's better to just batch them
up and have some kind of weekly cadence
where you can deal with a lot of quick
requests without having the overhead of
of email and I think these are all kind
of emails just one example of a lot of
different forces that can take away that
can kind of shatter your attention or
take away your time I think one of the
one of the most valuable concepts from
the effective executive is measuring
your time and early understanding where
your time goes and it is kind of
shocking and hilarious but really tragic
that we all think we know exactly where
our time goes but then when you measure
it you're not usually just like slightly
wrong you're like totally upside down so
this is a really valuable exercise for
anyone but actually like keeping a log
of like where you spend your time and
categorizing it I remember the first
time I just did this I was like all
right I'm running a company it's things
are going well I probably what do I
spend my time on Oh back then I was like
I spend my time on product and
recruiting and cetera and when I
actually did the the inventory like I
was spending like no time on those
things I was spending there was a lot of
yeah a lot of oppe back then like just
like responding to fit like following up
on favors or speaking gaygent so it
didn't really do anything for the
company and
there wasn't like a lot of like total
fat like that but but it just might what
you find is you write down your
priorities and you look at your time and
you find the things are totally
mismatched and so any mechanism you can
to to first understand where your time
goes and then make sure your priorities
actually match it I think at the end of
the day that's conceptually what you
want to do and then just understand that
you're gonna attend and then you also
want to offset that the tendency for to
be in this permanently reactive state
which whether that's because you're
getting emails that are other people's
requests or your calendar says one thing
usually when you your to-do list gets
too long you just try to you just sort
of do things randomly or just do
whatever the last thing your just
respond to whatever showed up most
recently in your inbox or what blinked
at you or what yelled at you loudest in
the last you know hour and that's not a
that's not effective compared to having
setting your own priorities and
measuring yourself against them and this
is separate topic but I think technology
needs to do a lot better job of helping
us do that because it's really hard and
then especially as you're in any kind of
organization
you're gonna that the the fires will get
dealt with first and that's that's not a
bad thing or that that's like necessary
you can't not put out the fires but then
the important stuff the I'd say
Eisenhower had this fake side of the
world versus urgent
yeah the matrix there the quadrants I
guess was yeah yeah the 2x2 is an
important and urgent like you just in
eliminating stuff that's not important
not urgent but but really the biggest
prior crisis of prioritization is like
how do you make sure that you do that
you elbow out time the important not
urgent stuff because the important and
urgent stuff will get taken care of but
then you end up with a lot of stuff
that's not important or urgent not
important or not important not urgent
and you really want a limb I cut those
down as much as possible because
otherwise a lot of the fires if you
actually a root cause analysis think
about like why did why was this fire in
the first
you kind of climb that ladder a couple
of rungs like why did this happen why
this happen or why does happen because
that why did that happen because of that
you find that just a little bit of
planning would have would have
eliminated the need to fight that fire
and so but it's really easy to spend
your days kind of doing the equivalent
of ping ping down a lot of like high
interest credit card debt with your time
by just doing fighting all these fires
and not actually putting them out at
their route so something I do on that
front now is either there's a concept
called no meeting Wednesday which i
think is popular around the valley maybe
it originated Facebook I'm not sure but
we've sort of had half-heartedly adopted
that and I have heartedly adopted that
for a while but I remember there was a
like I really want to do this because
there's all this planning and like all
these things that are important that
that were the cost of me not creating
clarity for my team is super high and I
sat down with my assistant at the time
and I was like hey I need to like please
don't schedule stuff on Wednesday like
it's really it's really important that I
work on this particular project and you
know it's just not gonna get done unless
there's some unless I have like a full
day or like many hours of uninterrupted
time and she's like but she's like but
blah blah blah has this and it's
important and blah blah blah has this
and it's important and blah blah has
this and it's important and I'm like
there will never be a day where there
isn't something quote important you know
ramming up and so it's dawned on me in
that conversation I'm like this [ __ ]
this is all important like that but it's
not and and so I was like look just I
really want if it is important just
schedule it on Saturday
I'll come into the office I'll do all
those things and then miraculously those
things kind of ended up doing themselves
and adopting no meeting Wednesday was
utterly transformative in terms of
actually being able to think and make
progress on the most important thing so
otherwise you just you lift up your head
and you finally six months have passed
on some important unquote important
priority of yours and there's been no
progress so think about how do you
develop systems
and how do you build in time for
reflection in elbow at the time for for
you to think and set direction I think
that's that's probably one that's one of
the biggest mistakes that people make
and one of the concepts from effective
executive is like a lot of that stuff
only makes praat that doesn't that stuff
doesn't make progress with a half-hour
slot in a meeting of 10 or in a day of
ten hours of half-hour meetings like you
there's a minimum quantum of time for
deep thought or deep work that you need
and so anyway there's a lot of really
conceptual found great conceptual
foundations and effective executive
about your time and effectiveness and in
disambiguating busyness from
effectiveness and then the concept of
leverage and high open management and a
focus on output so those those two books
have pretty much conceptually everything
you need but then implementing it in
practice is a lot harder uh-huh yeah
we're going to talk about the practice
quite a bit I think also in this
conversation I want to circle back to a
few things you mentioned because I think
they're really important the first is
the eisenhower matrix i think it might
be referred to as which which people can
look up on their own time but the the
correlating in some respects may be
exercise that I think Drucker brings up
in the effective executive is the jar or
mason jar and if people can visualize
this very easily but if you have a mason
jar and next to the mason jar you have a
handful of large rocks that can fit into
the jar then you have a bunch of smaller
pebbles and then you have a pile of sand
all of which has come out of the jar if
you put in the big rocks first ie your
most critical tasks which may or may not
be urgent then you can fit in the
pebbles then you can fit in the sand and
you screw on the top and it's nice and
neat but if you put in the sand first
the whole thing falls apart right you
you you cannot take the same volume of
rocks and pebbles and sand and get it
into the jar and which which visually
from from an energy standpoint is very
easy to understand and the the time
audit though as you described is
so important for people to do because
very often even your calendar is not a
good reflection of how you in fact spend
your time and if you look at say self
reporting in dietary studies where
they're observational and people are
going home and then coming back and
reporting every two weeks or something
like that if you if you ask people to
estimate their caloric consumption it's
mmm almost always like thirty to forty
percent off it's not a small difference
and I think the same thing happens with
time really really routinely the the
blocks of time actually you know what
I'm going to get I'm gonna make a
reading recommendation and then I'm
gonna come back to this name which of
course you're gonna be very familiar
with but for people who really want to
also get a teaser for what you'll read
more about the effect of executive if
there's an essay I might be getting it
the headline slightly off but you'll be
able to find it make your schedule
manager schedule yep bye bye Paul Graham
and the legendary PG who are going to
come back to is a good place to start
but I want to rewind the clock for a
second and ask you why did you stop the
SAT online prep company so I started the
SAT prep company in 2004 and then I went
back to school finished my undergrad and
then a couple things happened so still I
was I after graduation I started working
as an engineer at a network security
company and I was still moonlighting on
this on accolade the SAT prep company
but I found myself in the situation
where I was like it was just like harder
and harder to make progress on the SAT
Pro company and I wasn't really sure
what was going on because I I just felt
like it was it took more and more
willpower to like pedal or I felt like I
don't know whether it's because I felt
like I was pedaling harder but not
getting anywhere or one way or another
just but over time it took a lot more
willpower to work on it and so I found
myself procrastinating with all these
like side projects
and I mean now I recognize all this as
burnout and and an A+ there aren't a lot
of good things about burnout but
sometimes it can steer the positive
element is consider attention to things
that are more worthwhile but then I was
worried because I'm like oh my god I'm
like so unproductive and I'm you get mo
wallowing in this like guilt I was
raised Catholic so like this Catholic
guilt of like not you know I'm not
working hard enough this company is not
successful and on a phone like that and
it's like totally not helpful but and so
I'm like oh my god am i broken like am I
not capable of working hard what's wrong
with me
but then I would like well one good news
I started working on this like pokerbot
that started and it played with real
money like I like got past the security
on the poker client this is John six so
I figure out how to like make all that
work and then watch it's kind of my
Frankenstein moment as the bot comes to
life and starts playing on real poker
tables and so this idea that you can
have poker bus was like totally false
but and but I was possessed it was like
were you hunting was the bot was
Frankenstein's monster winning well I
mean the Frank is Frankenstein was like
not too not too smart in the beginning
so like there's some it that the thing
starts moving the mouse and playing car
or you're playing the hand then gets
confused because it heads there some
like obscure multiple split pot or
something that I just didn't write the
code to handle that situation so the
thing crashes and folds your aces and
you're like okay awesome this is what AI
looks like but it was scaring my family
because I was I was living in Boston but
then we have a little summer place in
New Hampshire and I was like my family's
like okay you know come up this weekend
we're all gonna be at the lake and I'm
like okay and then I get to the lake and
I'm start unpacking my trunk and I had
like three monitors and like always
computers and I'm like I mean this is
like a little cottage on the pond it's
not set up to be like Mission Control so
I'm like putting monitors
stove my parents are like what are you
doing they're kind of used to me having
all these side projects so they're just
like I hope it's not illegal just
[Laughter]
unfortunately that side project had to
stop because of that like the potent
fall of 2006 it became like went from my
kind of borderline to like very illegal
to do online poker so that that project
ended but but so what's that about what
I took from that was like well first I'm
like I'm not broken
like I'm super capable working hard it's
just like I need to find something that
I'm really motivated by and so that was
a relief and then and then along the way
so I continued to work on the SAT prep
thing but then the kind of the founding
story of Dropbox was well I had to use
well the founding sort of strong Dropbox
arts was forgetting my thumb drive and
going on the Chinatown bus which I'll
get to but but before that I kept having
these problems working with my
co-founder because or collaborating with
him because we didn't have an offer well
we bootstrapped the company so we didn't
raise any money and and we didn't have
an office we didn't work out at the same
place and we didn't have servers we
don't have anything so we would just
like email stuff back and forth and I
had to work on multiple computers so I'd
kept carrying around this thumb drive
and having these elaborate scripts that
would back up our the SAT prep company
kind of to all of our files to a server
and then eventually I was like alright
well I want to that I I graduated from
colleges about 2006 late 2006 a lot of
my friends had lived in New York and
they're like you got to come out it's a
lot of fun here you know just come out
for the weekend and I have a dilemma
because I'm like well I I need to get
some stuff done for my company but I
also want to go to New York and I'm like
maybe if I take the Chinatown bus or if
I ride the bus I can get I can have four
and a half hours each way so then I'll
have ten out of ten hours should be
enough time to do what I need to do is
you know you know the
rationalisations we we come up with and
some I go get felt if I take the bus
that's I'm green light to go to New York
then I get on the bus and I've forgotten
my thumb drive so and then crack problem
yeah yeah back to self flagellation I'm
like I can't I'm like I keep doing this
I suck you know I'm not like I hate my
thumb drive I'm like I hate me
but I'm like oh my god I just cannot
deal with this problem I'm like an F
this is so stupid like I'm so sick of
like even it like emailing myself a file
like what is the question for CH there's
no question force that's the right
answer I'm like what do you think of the
physical equivalent of that like taking
an envelope putting something in at
putting your own name in the to and from
putting in the mailbox and getting it
back I'm like this is what we do to like
manage our files that Karen thumb drive
all the things we used to have to do it
I'm like I never wanna have this problem
again so I on the bus I open up the
editor and started writing some code in
Python that basically was this seed that
sprouted into Dropbox but it's weird and
I was just like totally possessed with
that problem because I'm an engineer
again I'm like an engineer by upbringing
my favorite classes at school other than
some of the stuff we've talked about was
or like algorithms distribute systems
you know and I found myself at a
crossroads were like look I love
standardized tests as much as any human
possibly can I guess but it was the
couple things happened so one is I like
pause I'm like okay I'm working on this
company I'm kind of burning out part of
why is because I I thought about like
okay even if all of my dreams come
through and like everything we hope for
happens with this SAT prep company then
I'm like then with them then what and
I'm like I'm like king of SAT prep right
and there's nothing I mean I I think
that's fine and like people need help
with these things and and but I'm like
that's not what I want to do I'm just
picturing this kind of like cardboard
crown
and I'm like and that's only if
everything goes well that's like if all
of our dreams come true so I'm like I
need to do something else and so I ended
up with these side projects and then
found myself getting totally obsessed
with first the pokerbot but then even
more so with Dropbox and so sometimes
it's hard you know like how do you deal
with burnout how do you know if you're
doing the right thing because these are
really hard questions I mean for me sort
of listening sometimes a lot of
procrastination is unhealthy but
sometimes that little voice is leading
you in a much better direction mm-hmm so
I want to Cirque I want to bring this
back to the dot-dot-dot that I left
after Paul Graham and we can certainly
go in any possible direction you want to
take it but for people who don't know
Paul Graham maybe you could maybe could
describe Paul Graham certainly as close
to a demigod as one can probably get
among many many young entrepreneurs and
older entrepreneurs yeah in Silicon
Valley who is Paul Graham what is Y
Combinator and can you describe your
first meeting with Paul Graham yes
so Paul Graham is best known as the as
one of the the founders of Y Combinator
so they are which is an incubator for
startups they and they were our first
investors and and they also invested in
a lot of great companies including
Airbnb stripe a lot of them and Paul was
before starting Y Combinator he had
written he was entrepreneur himself so
he started a company called via web back
in the dot-com or the first combooo m--
and sold it and then he had a lot of
really provocative and insightful essays
on startups that gained a big following
and he was also one of the creators or
at least was very early in the
conversation around using Bayesian
methods using this kind of math to do
spam filtering so he's also one of the
originals or one of the architects or at
least involved in that community of
people who have figured out
get rid of spam and that's actually how
I first heard about him but then he
started writing about startups and then
ran this experiment that became Y
Combinator but it was actually called
the summer founders program and I was
digging through some old email about it
because I this was the precursor to Y
Combinator I applied with my SAT prep
company to that and was rejected but
then managed to get into Y Combinator a
couple years later so so I guess the
first virtual meeting of applying to be
funded didn't go well the first
in-person meeting was probably probably
hold on hold on pause why didn't why
didn't the virtual meeting go well well
we didn't really eventually meet it was
just sorta like it was like a college
admissions thing is you we you you it's
open application anybody who wants to
submit an application kit for for the
summer founders program which is
basically it was like the same thing as
Y Combinator like you get a little bit
of money and they'll come together it
was like sort of Y Combinator version
one but I applied and then get in and I
was super disappointed so that didn't go
well and then but a couple years later I
wanted to apply again with Dropbox and
this is skipping ahead a little bit but
I had so I I had the idea for Dropbox
started working on it and I wanted to do
YC because a good friend of mine or for
many reasons but in another friend of
mine this guy Adam Smith no relation he
was when I friends from college he did
YC in 2006 and had an awesome experience
and I had like a front-row seat to that
and saw how much fun they're having and
then their company was just in like a
much faster trajectory because of YC and
I'm like oh my god I want something like
that but then I hope so I start thinking
about applying for YC with Dropbox and
one of the good things about coming from
college admissions is you sort of learn
how these admissions processes work and
YC was not really that different you
have a lot of people applying for a few
spots and so in addition to getting the
scores and the grades and everything one
of the things you can do is try to stand
out and do something kind of
unique and so I'm like alright well
maybe to get in help me get into I see
I'll try to put a video out about how
Dropbox works and Y Combinator also had
their oh they just started this new this
new site called hacker news which is
kind of like Reddit first startup news
and and I'm like what does I mean I
thought like I had an I had a hunch so
I'm like what do you what does Paul do
all day I think he probably does what
most of us do which is just hit refresh
on hacker news all the time so I'm like
maybe if we put a video on Hacker News
maybe I can get in front of the Dean of
Admissions here get Paul's attention and
then go from there it actually worked so
I made and and I I there's a concept
from a book that I had read on that roof
called guerilla marketing which is like
how do you get attention and you and
users for your product if you have no
[ __ ] you Jay Conrad Levinson or
something like that yeah I forget
something like that it's like how do you
do that when you have no money so and so
they're like all these so that it's the
the tactic of putting a video on Hacker
News or creating a viral video is that
that was a seed that was planted by
reading guerrilla marketing and so but I
made a screencast where just like a like
a three minute demo of how Dropbox works
cuz I wasn't ready to ship the code but
I wanted some feedback and I wanted to
get into YC and that video both got me
into YC and it got me a co-founder but I
didn't know that at the time so coming
back to what so then what happened with
this meeting with Paul so I put the
video on Hacker News it hits the top of
hacker news for multiple days it's a
long time built about the type of hacker
that that can't happen anymore because
for a bunch of reasons but but it was
like I was pretty happy about that
and then I'm like okay this is so far
the plan seems to be working I'm just
like keep hitting refresh on my inbox
I'm like maybe I wonder if Paul has seen
it and then lo and behold I get an email
from Paul Graham saying like hey it
looks pretty cool but you need a
co-founder because they did especially
at the time they didn't like single
founders applying and I didn't have a
co-founder you
this was this was before I met Arash so
it's like Oh God
because the part the only prompt was I
agreed with him the only problem was the
application deadline was had already
passed I already applied and the
interviews were in like two weeks and so
I needed a co-founder in two weeks which
is like saying like hey I know you're
not dating anyone but you need to get
married by right and so a hilarity
ensued but but then I was I can't flew
out to San Francisco like I'm like
trying to shake the trees for any
co-founder candidates I haven't thought
of because for one reason another all of
my close friends and people that would
have been the the folks that I would
have leaned on like the timing wasn't
good they didn't want to do it whatever
else and so but I I found another friend
of mine I was actually getting managed
to get a friend of mine interested out
in San Francisco but he's like okay I'm
interested I don't know but I want to
know what PG thinks before I make a
decision so I'm like okay great
and I'm like it's a Tuesday my flight
that's a Tuesday at like 1:00 p.m. my
flight back to Boston leaves it like
10:00 or 11:00 so I'm like oh actually
wait this is YC has its dinners on
Tuesdays maybe I could just like drive
down to Mountain View and just like
pitch Paul maybe they are I like fly
down 101 and like the plan was like
working pretty well I got it I got to IC
I went in the office as expected people
were just chilling and kind of there was
some downtime and so and so I go like
knock on like I go I go to Paul's office
and sure enough he's in there he's just
chillin well Mike hey Paul do have a
minute
I just wanted you know I just wanted to
show you something I'm working on and
he's like nope I'm busy and I'm like
okay look we booked I'm like
I can almost see her screen I know
you're just like really reading hacker
news right now actually busy but it's
like awkward so I step outside and I
talked to Jessica who was an his is
partner in co-founding my see together
and and his wife and I talked to Jessica
I'm like hey look Jessica and I had met
Jessica before so I'm like Jessica I'm
really started to bother you guys I just
have a co-founder who was like looking
for some feedback from Paul to make his
co-founder decision you know I gotta fly
back in like four hours and I'd swear I
won't take more than 60 seconds of
Paul's time do you think it's okay if if
I go in there and she's like oh wait I
drew of course like no problem like
Paul's not doing anything just like just
he'll it'll be fine so I go back in
there and it's like detonation it's like
I said like three words and Paul's like
no he's like I'm not gonna see your
stupid demo the whole reason we have an
application processes so that randos
like you don't just like show up here
and bother us it's like no please leave
and so I'm like okay thanks Jessica
thanks Paul like my friend that's I'm
like this is not gonna be good I'm like
this is a ruff-ruff return to San
Francisco so needless to say the
co-founder situation did not work out
you're like there Paul's Paul's thinking
about it let me get back to you well I
did I did meet with the Dean of
Admissions he just thinks I'm an [ __ ]
I think I think he's coming around oh
yeah defective that was a tough plane
ride home but it's good training like
this is this is yeah this is like the
new normal if you're starting a company
so let me let me just hit pause for one
second what were you what were you
saying to yourself on the way back like
what was the self-talk on the plane ride
back I was like I have I could not have
like eff this up any worse if I had
tried
because like an IHOP co-founder and I'm
like I might have been able to get in if
I just like hadn't like maximally pissed
off Paul anyway now I have no co-founder
no YC and probably no company and I like
two weeks left to like resolve this may
or may be a week left result anyway not
a lot of time so it was bad yeah I was
like I don't really see how this all
kind of lives happily ever after
then what happened so then but my kind
of shaking the trees in San Francisco
did help so I met it turned out I met a
guy named Kyle Kyle vocht
who I'd met at the MIT entrepreneurs
Club so he's an MIT student he dropped
out here he had just dropped out to do
justin.tv which became twitch and then
Kyle then later started Cruz which did
great so kyle has done well and then I
was complaining the Kyle I'm like hey
Kyle like I need a co-founder I you know
is there anyone you'd recommend and he
he recommended me to turned out that
Kyle and Arash were floor mates at East
Campus at MIT and so he's like oh you
should talk to her oh Sh and then a day
or two later I got an email from her OSH
saying hey he was like a he was a senior
undergrad at MIT computer science
student and and he was like hey I got
this email from Raj and said like hey I
saw your video on Hacker News and Kyle
said you're looking for a co-founder you
know maybe we should talk and then it
was kind of insane like we met in the
Student Center maybe we got coffee one
more time and then he drops out of
school
he's like a senior he drops off with a
semester left you know I was figuring
this is gonna be like a process right I
might like talk to his parents and like
reassure them but no like we hang out
for like two hours and then he then like
then we'd the two of us commit to like
spending most of our waking lives
together for the
Shelagh future I don't think either of
us really understood that at the time
fortunately it all has worked out great
but so but but against all odds so a
rush and I team up
I think Paul forgot about his meeting
with me or didn't like put the two
together so we did our interview and we
got into IC and it was funny cuz like we
and we're doing the interview
we're milling around waiting for we go
down in the morning we go get lunch we
come back to the car our our car got
broken into and our laptops got stolen
Oh God
but fortunately all of our stuff was on
Dropbox so we were like patient zero for
all this and then we got the happy phone
call from from Paul saying hey we want
to fund you guys and and I mean I don't
know it was it was nuts though so I I
don't know if this has changed but for
some period of time I think it's
probably still the case but but you
could correct me if I'm wrong I mean
Dropbox was far and away the most
successful investment that why comment
in her had ever made and that by I mean
certainly Dropbox has done incredibly
well at what point did you go to go to
Paul's office knock knock hey Paul like
in brackets now we're friends by any
chance do you remember when I came in
during Tuesday on a Tuesday not too long
ago no did you ever bring that up with
him or did he learn about it through
some other means I like to remind him
about it every couple every year or two
first he's like totally in Baron like he
didn't put any of these things together
you didn't know he didn't remember it
he's like I was so awful at this app so
that mostly it's just they they both
Paul and just go turn like bright red
and they don't like to talk about it
which is like why I like to keep poking
at it everything no it's all I mean it's
all good I would have done this yeah of
course
yeah well he did tell you I'm visiting
I was super obnoxious but some was
dropped it was Dropbox the original name
of the company yeah it was Wow so so
just from day one you had the name that
stuck oh for you getting the domain it
was get Dropbox calm getting the Dropbox
calm domain name was oh my god that was
that was a journey so if there was a
good I don't know I'm like I'm like
starting to shake a little bit going I
don't know how about illuminating this
that this story is but they don't know
let's talk about it these people people
I mean people run into this stuff I'm
sure I'm sure we can I'm sure we can
pull some lessons from that so I I
remember get Dropbox yeah so a rush and
I felt like so the the name Dropbox
actually the behind the music version
like the story behind the name is also
probably unintuitive or like not what
you'd expect so you asked what am I like
what was I like in high school and the
answer was like basically he's a huge
nerd who likes computer games and that's
true
one of the things we would do is we'd
all bring our we would like a bunch of
friends and I would bring our computers
to someone's house and we play games and
so back in the day these things were
called LAN parties they are about as
Google as if now and in you know you all
show up and play it all till you play
till sunrise and and and so on but you
bring a bunch of people together and
often someone doesn't have the the right
Maps or the right patch or the right
whatever and so we had a convention like
you just create a folder called your
Dropbox that's shared and writable by
anyone and that's how he would exchange
files so that people could play games
and then it's I remember this it was
like Christmas 2006 I'm trying to come
up with a name for Dropbox door didn't
have a name then I the initial name
I had like some what the name before I
was as busy photoshopping a logo is the
initial iteration of it was folder
anywhere which
catchy catchy yes which just was which
was probably the first indication that I
had a brilliant future in marketing and
out for this and then some like in
Photoshop trying to make a logo for
folder anywhere and I'm like of course
they're probably logos like a literal
filter or something it's like totally a
name and then I start and I'm like what
and and I you know believe it folder
anywhere comm was actually available so
I thought was the proud owner of older
anyway huh then I realized that I did
search and I found there's a company
called files anywhere mm-hmm and I was
like no like I can't that it's like I
can't now I can't name it folder
anywhere and so I'm sort of I'm on aim
talking to one of my friends from high
school and I'm like god I don't know
what to call this thing you know folder
anywhere is taken like maybe I should
just you know maybe maybe I should call
it Dropbox like from the you know from
from high school there from land parties
and he's like okay whatever and and then
and then I Dropbox like I'm not
available so I got get Dropbox calm but
then um so we just lived with get
Dropbox account for a while I tried to
you can sometimes look up who owns a
domain and contact them so I try I
actually did I amended that I managed to
get the guy call and I'm like hey are
you Dropbox calm you know or are you
using it and the the guy was like yes
I'm using it for a project I'm like okay
well you have any interest in like
selling it or you know coming up with
some kind of arrangement he's like no
I'm like okay cool so that's February at
2007 and then then we then we get
distracted with the whole getting into I
see finding a co-founder all that doing
YC and then I landed then we moved to
San Francisco in September and I'm like
we really need to get this domain name
and unfortunately a rush and I had
totally fallen in love with it so like
we weren't really we kind of only had
one plan
by the way that's that's called a great
negotiating position yeah awesome expect
so we like
well since the finish Zipcar and show up
at someone's house worked so well the
first time we're gonna do it again so
turned out the guy lived in Pleasanton
and he was an entrepreneur here's
someone who's like nearby and should be
sympathetic to our cause at least to
some extent and I'm like and I call him
I'm like how's that project going
because there's obviously no project and
and he's just kind of being difficult
and so I'm like I'm like okay god damn
it we would get off the phone and I'm
like Irish let's just like show up in
this guy's house let's just see what
happens
so jump in another zip car we go to the
that we drop to go to the like the the
corner store and get there like most
expensive bottle of $20 champagne we can
get in as a car and go to his house and
it's like 9:00 at night so I don't know
it seemed like a good idea at the time
so we show up and and then he was kind
of I think he was kind of shocked kind
of amused like let's us in we have a
suite we start talked and he's like
we're like hey look you know we're
pretty serious about this thing we're
doing you know we'd love you know if
it's true that you're not actually doing
anything with the domain you know like
help us understand what you're trying to
accomplish not in a noxious way just
like you know but but at least consider
this alternative where you know we use
Dropbox calm you know we've got some
really good folks who are excited about
this in involved whether that's Y
Combinator we just gotten funding from
Sequoia our first venture capital
investor who's one of the best in the
world and so we're like oh you told them
that yeah right yeah it's really
building up our leverage here so this
would be called hemorrhaging leverage at
the same time you know these these
the frameworks don't completely account
for everything because if you don't sure
if you don't actually help them
understand why they should be interested
and you hold all your cards to the vest
and nothing happens and that's what we
experienced over the last seven months
so we're like okay so like at least get
sketch out a case that a reasonable
person would look at and be interested
in so and then he's like cool it's
interesting I got to talk to a friend
and you know why don't you why don't we
touch base soon and I'm like great well
it's like Friday I'm like well it was
like a Friday night I think and I'm like
will be I'll be back on Monday and we're
in the ride back going over the Bay
Bridge I'm like holy [ __ ] we might
actually be able to get this thing like
this guy's been impenetrable and so
difficult like were both kind of in awe
and just like this is such a positive
thing so we go back on Monday and he's
just like yep thought about it not
interested thanks bye
and we're like are you kidding I just is
this for real like no I'm like I I'm
like where is this gonna go are you
gonna like what are you gonna bequeath
to this domain to your children like
what the hell but he was just like
totally wouldn't budge and so that was a
much sadder drive back so then this guy
and then there's just kind of nothing
for a couple years or for a year and
then we launch drop out we put a we
launch Dropbox publicly and then all
these confused people start going to
Dropbox calm and and presumably start
trying to get and they they wanted to
get into the beta so this is this is
later in the air so that they and this
so they he starts getting all these
emails from people I think probably
March 2008 who were looking to get into
the Dropbox beta and then he he does got
he and I'll end this story in a
reasonable amount of time but we like so
he then he kind of goes dark he puts a
privacy shield up on the domain then
puts up an adwords landing page so like
dropbox calm like doesn't know it
like a GoDaddy parking page - like a
Google Adsense for domains page which
was a problem because then we're like oh
my god now this guy is like totally
cashing in like it's basically you go to
dropbox.com it was basically AdWords for
all of our competitors look and so I'm
just thinking of like I'm like what the
hell are we gonna do about this like our
investors think we're idiots for not
changing the name we're doing all these
like pointless and branding exercises
that did not go well like to try to find
an alternate name so I'm just like oh my
god like what what are we gonna do and
the answer was read the federal
copyright code and trademark code and I
became it looks kind of an expert in
cyber trademark law I get an armchair
expert in the stuff and it turns out you
can't just like get a domain from
someone for no reason like you can't
just be like oh you're not using it so
therefore it's mine anymore you could be
like oh you're not using that land to
give it to me right but it is also
illegal for someone to intentionally
confuse confused customer can confuse
your customers so I can't just like say
that or you're you know I can't sell
paper towel or towel or I can't sell
like Kleenex with three e's to confuse
people or whatever so you intentionally
confusing consumers is a problem
and we had another whole Odyssey trying
to get the Dropbox trademark which oh
that's not as interesting but I'm like
we had a problem we didn't actually have
the register trademark either but he was
now making money from infringing on our
common law trademark rights and so I'm
working with this crazy trademark of
like a trademark and domain
attorney and so we sue him for federal
for trademark infringement and so that
got his attention and and which we would
not have done like we're not we weren't
just trying to push him around I mean
it's really he was you're trying to
profit off of confusing our customers so
we were for sure got on our high horse
after that
and I mean that was a comical whole
experience but eventually he's like okay
okay okay
you know halt all like let's this is his
own point to have this lawsuit you know
I'll give you guys or I'll sell you guys
a domain I'm like okay well like we can
offer you stock or cash he's like I'll
just take cash so we paid him 300 grand
got the domain lived I mean that was
such a like sending that first email
from Dropbox com to Paul and Jessica was
a huge triumph but what even though we
offered him stock at that like other
would have been at the seed round but
most guy worth like multiple hundreds of
millions of dollars to them I think what
you can take away from this it's like
there's just no manual for that right
you got a right kind of wing it and
there are a lot of things that are the
equivalent even today I'm just kind of
getting in the zip car with a bottle of
champagne and hoping for the best and
and you know sometimes we get really
good cards sometimes we get really bad
cards but you just got to kind of roll
with it and so between finding a
co-founder getting the domain each each
of those is definitely those are
definitely memorable points along the
journey well we were chatting a bit
before we started recording about the
psychological aspects of say prepping
for starting a company and I want to tie
that to a company you mentioned earlier
which is reddit assume you mentioned
that hacker news is sort of reddit for
the computer science slash hacker subset
Rhett and I remember having Alexis
co-founder on this podcast and he told
me about meeting really early on with an
executive at Yahoo they're really
excited they went in and they shared
their numbers and the executives said
Wow something along the lines of oh my
god you're just a rounding error for
Yahoo
and it was so insulting that Alexis took
you are rounding her I think it was and
put it on the wall in the office right
but that's that is one of several
different responses that that are
possible right they mean there are there
are certainly people it would be crushed
by that it could be the end and I don't
remember exactly where this quote is
from but I want to talk about when this
came out and how you what the self talk
was so the okay this there's an article
being written about Dropbox and I think
the quote was quote fortunately the
Dropbox founders are too stupid to know
everyone's already tried this and quote
yeah so when did that happen and how did
you and anyone else involved respond to
it yeah so that was very early I would
say it's probably within the first year
and probably the most well I think what
happens is you'll get well I mean I just
think they even back to that first video
that I put on Accra news a lot of the
actually a lot of the commentary was
positive people like I would use
something like this it's good like and
and it was really and that was really
encouraging so I did so on the one hand
half the peanut gallery saying that the
other half is saying like listing all
these reasons why it's been tried before
and won't work that and then even if it
does work like Microsoft Google
everybody's going to kill us and here's
why it's never been a business and here
all these other ones that have never
succeeded that it did and the things I
agreed with him I was like yeah you're
probably right
like I don't really see how we survive
as I mean anything in 2007 I don't see
how we kind of make it through you know
to Mount Doom
that's a little like plucky band of the
two of us so and then invariably every
investor we talked to would raise
similar concerns so that the feedback is
all pretty negative so it's easy to say
like oh just ignore it all but you you
kind of have to you have to be balanced
so on the one hand we did get
encouraging feedback in the beginning so
people were like drop this is cool I
will use this it sounds great
you know and I knew that I needed it and
then I wasn't like trying to create a
billion dollar company I was trying to
just like solve a problem and so I think
setting your sights low in the beginning
ironically can be helpful because you're
not putting so much pressure on yourself
I just like if I'm sure the cool thing
it'll be one of this is just another
side project on a number of side
projects and like let me not suffocate
it by putting all these crazy
expectations on it so I think that's
pretty important and then people go when
did you know it was a success it's like
well it was sort of a different point it
was like the goalposts for success kept
successively moving back so even just
having a video was a big milestone and
launching the private beta as a big
milestone and there are a bunch of
milestones but so is sort of a
continuous product that process more
than like oh is this one moment in time
but yeah there were people who had very
good arguments about why this wasn't
gonna be successful and that's why I
think you have to have you have to have
sort of have alternate you have to have
both thick skin and thin skin forget
I've kind of get that balance right
because if you just have just ignore all
of the feedback and dismiss it all then
you're probably gonna have some kind of
blind spot and you're gonna you're gonna
miss some important information so just
because they came but but just because
they came to that conclusion doesn't
mean that their assumptions were all
correct and that's why you also need to
have enough thick skin to know when to
like when to be a little bit dismissive
or not listen to everything and part of
what helps with that is having
conviction and conviction that comes
from being able to think from first
principles
and pay less attention to people's
conclusion like the outputs of people's
conclusions as much as the inputs into
those conclusions so what does that mean
well people said that ok the drop box is
not gonna be successful because if
people have tried in a million times and
that is that is true and anybody who
that's like factually true it's not you
can't debate that but that would have
been true for mobile like every phone
every mobile thing before the iPhone or
every mobile software company every app
like was a total failure before the
iPhone world changes suddenly it's the
right time and so if you study history
of Technology or history business you
realize okay that that argument is not
in and of itself causal so the the what
you want answer is like a why is that
incorrect it's like well actually there
there are a lot of good ideas that are
bad ideas for a while because the timing
is wrong but then the timing comes right
because of some discontinuity in tech
and like then in well it's like the
innovators dilemma or others will
illustrate that and so if you really
understand these if you understand
that's why it's important to build these
mental models because you were like all
right this is my framework for how the
world works and I keep refining it what
these people are missing the key you can
confirm that that just because something
has happened before I like has failed
before doesn't mean it will always fail
in the future can still fail but but
that kind of conviction came from an
understanding or a belief in a worldview
and framework of like AI here's how
here's how I think business works or
here's how to think about an idea like
ours so but that said it's not so I
think there's a how do you receive
advice and how do you sort of develop
first principles thinking which we
talked about but then like that doesn't
make it feel any better when people like
your idea sucks and you're gonna fail or
even worse than that like you are stupid
really yeah at super ad hominem right um
yeah people are not so first of all I
think you have to have a sense of like
this is normal like they just don't take
it too personally because that's this
thing you know you want to take it you
do want to take you want to receive the
feedback and like try to extract the
kernel of
that's useful from it but not feel
obligated to to accept the whole thing I
think more broadly
you just have to whether it's getting
criticism or just a lot of the thing I
think one of the harder things about
running the company in general was I
just remember being in the beginning
being like oh my god like alright now we
like Sequoia has decided to invest in
our company against the odds now Sequoia
has decided to invest there they're
writing us a check for a million dollars
I hope they realize that like I've never
I've not I haven't like really done this
before and like oh god like that million
dollar it's great to kind of cash that
check but home an they're gonna be
looking for that money back at some
point like what are we gonna do and so
that's not there wasn't the I mean
they're probably a lot of things going
on in my head at the time but and then
like oh my god I've never really built a
successful company before I don't never
manage people really you know the idea
of Dropbox being at a hundred person
company is like terrifying like I'm this
treadmills just gonna go faster and
faster until like I'm violently thrown
off of it
like how am I gonna deal with that and
in a lot of me also felt like okay well
I'll just like build the company until
it's like successful enough or makes
enough money where I just not to worry
about money anymore and then I had like
a like as soon as I get to that I don't
know this was like some kind of theory
I'm like alright as soon as I get to
that level of success I'll just stop and
like just so I don't screw it up
but then interestingly that the that
goal post kept moving back and moving
back and moving back so I think it's
it's never really been about the money
but you can read in the Y Combinator
application like that's now public we
put that out there I'm like oh wait
there are like I would if I had a
million dollars after taxes after six
months of work I'd consider that a
pretty good deal so so but but but more
on the the more on just like that what
do you do when you're like oh my god
this is like pretty uncomfortable I've
never done anything like this before
I might screw it up you need so your
instinct will to be to run away from
that feeling
and what you need to learn to do is run
towards it because that's just gonna
keep keep having and keep having like
you know room drives show up this guy's
house I don't know so maybe we'll get
arrested out but not we're gonna do it I
don't think that's the best example
there's so many things where it's like
you just got to kind of figure it out
and keep going and then one of the great
things from that that Ben wrote in his
book the hard thing about our things is
the hardest part of being a CEO is
managing your psychology and I didn't
really know what that meant at the time
I think I've been much better since now
so I think the first thing is I'm
comfortable with being uncomfortable
because and I and you think about
principles like Ray Dalio spook he's
like pain plus reflection equals
progress
people love the progress part or they
love growth but they don't love the pain
part and they don't bother to do the
reflection part so so understanding that
that isn't in the sort of zooming out
and understanding like deep personalized
it's like it's not really you this is
just like the process of growth it will
be painful or think of your journey as
more of an adventure rather than like a
final exam where you have to get
everything right and you only got one
shot I think that's that's pretty
important and then second is all right
you have to know it's everybody likes
the idea of growth and pushing yourself
but you also have to take care of
yourself like we have to find ways to
metabolize stress and avoid burnout and
for some reason people just they just
used the one tool of like pushing
themselves harder and then they break
and you know you wouldn't do that to
your car you wouldn't do that with like
a musical instrument so why would you do
that to yourself right so just to just a
positive as I had I I recall very
distinctly every time we've stayed at
the same hotel or been at the same event
and I've gone to the gym I've almost
always seen you in the gym I mean it
seems like you have just as a component
of that a physical practice to care for
the Machine and so to speak yeah I
wouldn't say I'm the best like athlete
by
but it's really important you have to do
enough so that you don't break down and
so and you got to figure out what that
is for you and and I know that's
something you really care about and and
the advice you have to offer your
readers be much better than whatever
advice I have but you need to do
something some kind of routine and stick
to it but just the basics of you know I
think some of the stoop the dumbest
advice that people get is like you know
not sleeping or wearing like or just
pursuing this idea that successful
people somehow work like 70 80 hour
weeks and that's the norm there are a
number of problems with that first it's
like usually not true it's usually more
of an indication the person's either
lack of awareness about where they're
spending their time or lack of
effectiveness if they need if their only
tool in the shed is like work more hours
all right
because just think about that like you
you know they're that is that has a
ceiling in terms of how much of an
advantage that can give you like yes you
want to work hard but if your only
advantage is like being able to work 20%
more hours than someone who's merely
very committed then you're not gonna
have outside results and you also I mean
they're so if there's any I have I have
a I think this meme that people that
successful people work hundred hour
weeks or something is is both false and
super harmful most the most the most
successful people I know actually work I
mean they have crunch times or they're
super busy but they otherwise have a
work week that looks more normal than
not and so that that was something I
didn't realize when I was starting out
but the basics of sleep eating well self
self-care exercise putting it on your
calendar not just wishful thinking and
hoping it'll sort of happen in the spare
moments like if you can't see these
things on your tape if you can't see
your priorities in your calendar if you
can't see your gym time on the calendar
it doesn't exist
totally so and then and then I think
like self awareness there's probably one
more we could talk about how to how to
metabolize stress and avoid burnout but
I think having like taking care of the
basic like having a good
Foundation and setting healthy
boundaries is pretty important and
having a sustainable workload the
self-awareness is pretty important and
being willing to like shine a hard light
on yourself and embracing that so for me
coaching has been super helpful coaching
meaning you have like an executive
culture I've had different ones over
time and and and really the and like I
go through the experience I'm like I'll
give us a shot so my friends have had
have spoken positively about it but it's
a little it's oh I say this is the first
part that I remember my first coaching
experience and like getting they do the
360 and then you sit down you do your
review of your results so sorry to pause
a 360 for people who don't know is where
you have any superiors peers employees
etc people who know you really well
interviewed about your strengths
weaknesses and so on would you have is
that fair to say yeah yeah well you get
all this feedback from all these you
know everybody you work closely with so
it's kind of overwhelming because you
get a lot of it and it's not all good so
and actually to this day like opening
those documents and lis reading all the
360 feedback is one of the most painful
it's like human experiences you can have
maybe that's a little hyperbolic but but
it's not fun it's at least not fun it's
not something I look forward to but it's
important so because you need to know
like it's much better just like know and
being able to do something about it like
I've been then with Ben's been a great
friend and mentor and he's like he was
reflecting he told me a quote that one
of his mentor's told him which is that
God gave us all weaknesses it's a
blessing to find out about them yeah you
know sobering you know but so but I went
through that yeah I just remember my
first coaching experience briefly like
you know sit you down there like first
page is usually like here are your
strengths and I'm like okay he's like my
coach was like you are really good you
really really care about people you love
building great relationship
and I'm like yep okay yeah that sounds
that sounds good
you're really creative you make new
ideas I'm like alright I'm enjoying this
coaching thing so far he's like you're
really comfortable in chaos like it
doesn't bother you that this stuff is
like so crazy I'm like yep it's like
okay better then and then flip to the
next page right now like it's never
weaknesses development areas
that's right opportunities for
completeness yeah they're about some
opportunities he's like you are really
conflict avoidant you don't make hard
people decisions people don't know what
you like where they stand I'm like okay
he's like you're unreliable you drop if
you drop balls you're not paying enough
attention to the things that are
important like okay and he's like and
you suck at planning people are confused
about what to do and I'm like okay and
then he's like look okay you're good
with people so and you like people to be
happy so you avoid conflict you are
creative you like new ideas so you don't
you don't pay attention to the routine
stuff you're comfortable in chaos so you
don't plan like these strengths are a
whole like their own weaknesses and
disguise like so and there's no one
who's like ten out of ten on everything
and that's that's why so you know
there's a lot of different philosophies
on what do you do with the feedback and
you know do you play more to your
strengths or do you think you need at
least get your weaknesses to a point
where they're not like destroying the
company but generally you want to play
to your strengths and that's one of the
key effective executive tenants but
other than that
and I think just self warrant like I'm
trying to understand yourself on all
kinds of different dimensions is really
valuable and I talked about the
Enneagram in your book yeah and that's
it's sort of like I'm I would call it
like a useful myers-briggs so most
people are familiar with myers-briggs
it's a personality typing system but
then you read it and it's like reading a
personality quiz on the internet you
sort of you remember you had some
letters and there's like some stuff but
you don't actually do anything with it
I found Enneagram to be similar in terms
of it
there are a limited number of
personality types but it's much more a
theory about what fundamentally
motivates people but what D motivates
them and so I know we don't have a ton
of time so I just say like check it out
any a gram is very valuable Ike I do it
my tea I was I was super skeptical I was
like it sounds like a cult and it kind
of is but it's been very helpful both to
do individually and with your team
because it just you sort of it what you
learn is like okay here the here are my
blind spots like I'm an NEA grab seven
these are like totally textbook
strengths and weaknesses of a seven that
they like they like new things they like
they're comfortable came out in chaos
but then they can become distracted and
and you know an unreliable conflict
avoid and things like that so just
knowing you always one way or another
you always want have an accurate map but
like what do you need to work on mm-hmm
how are you how are you introduced to
Enneagram well shows through my
co-founder but then mirage was
introduced to it through a guy named
gentry who is the founder of mailbox who
worked with us for for a while so yeah
I'm call it three or four years ago and
then Rob feels like you're gonna love
this it's great that it and I'm like it
sounds super weird but he was right so
it's it's been super helpful
awesome well I know we don't have a ton
of time left and maybe some time we'll
do a follow up with some wine and I'd
love to talk to you more about your
cadence and so on with an executive
coach maybe we can get to it another
time but I thought I thought we could
wrap up with another thing that you
mentioned in the book you know try with
mentors but I'd love to hear you talk
about it which is the tennis ball a
circle and the number 30,000 could you
tell us where this comes from and what
that means sure so I did the
commencement speech for MIT back in 2013
and I was like the whole premise was I'm
like I'm like I'm 30 I don't really like
I'm like I wait 20 years I'll say
something like way more insightful then
but I'm like all right well I got
the prompt the prompt that came up was
like what do I wish I had known what
would I tell my 23 year old self and if
I could sort of send the cheat sheet
back in time what would it have on it
and what I would put on that little
cheat sheet is as you said a tennis ball
a circle and the number 30,000 so the
tennis ball is really about finding that
thing you can become obsessed with and
so I think about like Dropbox or even
just so the side projects like the
pokerbot like I am both most productive
and happiest and most successful and
it's like when almost six lineup or when
the thing you're obsessed with overlaps
with something the world really needs or
values so but but like don't saddle like
find something that the tennis ball is
sorry what is it where does the time as
well come from I had this like really
lazy fat dog growing up who would but
when you showed her food or you showed
her tennis ball she would be just she
was just like go nuts and so you throw a
tennis ball for it so it was like she's
like this dish it was like watching like
like ham running on twigs or something
like it just bizarre is just funny like
and so I was like I'm like what you want
is to have like that ridiculous
expression on your face and just gonna
kind of be so obsessed with something
that you just don't care about anything
else I'd not overdo it but like but the
point is like you find something that
not just passionate about but like that
just like that you can become obsessed
with and just really love and something
you would do even if you weren't you
know even if want your job then the
circle concept is really there's a
saying by a guy named Jim Rohn that
you're you're an average of the five
people you spend the most time with and
I found that to be super true so in them
so the end the upshot is I choose to
choose wisely so whether that's the
literal five people you spend most time
with or just in the environment you end
so being like going to a or just fine
environment that will pull the best out
of you and so and I think that's been
true for me going to MIT really taught
me like what a good
engineer looks like and it's both
inspiring in terms of watching all these
people who are super like capable but
then also you get jealous and you're
like oh I you know I want to be that
good and so you you want to harness that
kind of negative energy into pushing
yourself to work harder so and that's
what I was true with her at school or
being in Y Combinator with other
founders like friendly competition there
or with my friends who were starting
companies being in San Francisco
all of those contributed massively to to
us to us making it and then finally
thirty thousand is is is really about do
you everybody lives on average humans
live on average for thirty thousand days
I was at first I was like okay yes this
is like a clinical truth not terribly
interesting because I think I just moved
to San Francisco and I was and I was
just like I couldn't sleep so I just
like on the internet reading stuff and I
came to came across that and i remmber
be like huh okay and I open the
calculator and I'm like all right I'm 24
at the time 24 times 365 I'm like oh my
god I'm like already 8,000 days now so
this idea of like life unfolding
infinitely in front of you is actually
not really true and so it's really
important to not just make every day
count but also understand that like
think of life more as an adventure or a
story more than how you think about life
as when you're graduating college which
is like life up until you graduate
college is just like a series of
checking off boxes and like getting
ready for stuff and performing and all
of your worldly achievements can be are
averaged into a GPA and so every mistake
is like brings that number down and like
it's something you have to like obsess
over and then college graduation is the
first day where that's not really true
anymore you don't really have a GPA
anymore you're not an average of all
your successes and failures like you
should change your mindset to life and
also to think of it more so just making
a story that's interesting not just not
trying to be perfect because I think
that's a trap that a lot of people fall
into so anyway those are when I thought
about you know if you were to play
everything over again a hundred times
who knows what would happen but if I
could just hand back a cheat sheet
that's what I would put on it that's how
you'd put on a tennis ball circle and
the number thirty thousand well drew I
know you have a very very busy time
ahead of you and I'm sure today is no
exception so I'll let you get back to
your day but do you have any closing
comments asks suggestions or anything
else for people who are listening to
this any any kind of parting comments
before we wrap up let's see I think I
just don't don't forget to have like
don't forget to have fun and like and I
said I think at the at the end of you
want to have like there's an obsession
with avoiding failure and and if you
think of it more as the failures aren't
really that important it's more how you
respond and even like what you what you
want to do is write an interesting story
not like a perfect story yes yes and I
mean the first thing they do with well I
shouldn't say this so definitively but
it's like a lot of screenwriters or
experienced will say you have to create
characters let the put the protagonist
who on some level the audience really
cares about and then torture them and
then they come out the other side that
is one of the recipes for writing a
successful screenplay and you know if
you're part of the human condition it
seems like that is gonna be a component
I one way or the other
well drew thank you so much for the time
I always enjoy chatting and hopefully we
get to hang again in person sometime
soon but I appreciate you carving out as
much time as you did to share your
stories with everybody for sure
well thanks Tim it's a lot of fun and
for everybody listening we will have
links to all the books mentioned
everything else that that drew may send
our way as well in terms of resources
all the things that we discussed hacker
news etc in the show notes which you can
find as always at Tim dialogue forward
slash podcast with all the other
episodes and until next time
thank you for listening hey guys this is
Tim again just a few more things before
you take off number one this is five
bullet Friday do you want to get a short
email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email for me every
Friday and that provides a little morsel
of fun before the weekend and five
bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek calm I'll
spell out and just drop in if your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoyed this
episode is brought to you by
wordpress.com
I love WordPress I have used it for so
many years it's my go-to platform for
blogging and creating websites I use
wordpress.com for everything every day
my site Tim to vlog is built on it the
websites for my books the tools of
titans tribe mentors all on
wordpress.com and the founder matt
mullenweg and my close friends has
appeared on this show many times the
search Matt Mullenweg tequila Ferriss or
quite exciting time whether you're
looking to create a personal blog a
business site of both you can make a
really big impact right out of the box
when you build on wordpress.com and
you'll be in good company
it's used by the New Yorker jay-z
Beyonce 538 TechCrunch heads CNN and
time just to name a handful
and one of my friends at Google she'll
remain nameless his home he said
wordpress.com offers the quote best out
of box
SEO imaginable unquote it's one of the
many reasons that nearly 30 percent of
the Internet is run are worthless you do
not need experience or to hire something
perhaps the best part where press comm
guide you through the entire experience
they have hundreds of designs and
templates that you can use and it's easy
to get started there's no need to worry
about security upgrades hosting any of
that they offer 24/7 support and they're
very very responsive if you have
questions and go right back to you and
this allows you to create the highest
quality with the least amount of
headache and friction so if you're
building a website period and my friends
come to me and ask what I use what I
recommend they use the answer is
wordpress.com
so check it out you want to get started
today learn more with a 15% discount off
any new plan go to wordpress.com polish
slash Tim create your website and find
the plan that's right for you to learn
more take a look wordpress.com 4/10 for
a 15% off your brand new whoops check it
out
this episode is brought to you by
99designs whether you need a logo custom
website app book cover or anything else
99designs was created to make great
design accessible to everyone that's you
and to make the process as easy as
possible I've used 99designs
for years now I've used them for book
covers some mock-ups for the 4-hour body
which went on to become a number one
York Times best seller illustrations of
all different types for the multi volume
natal of Seneca which you can check out
and other graphic design projects for a
long time now and I've been very
impressed by the quality of their
designers and illustrators and you don't
have to take my word for it you should
check out some of my projects at 99
designs com forward slash Tim I really
encourage you to take a look because you
will be impressed 99designs com forward
slash tim van den Designs has freelance
experts in more than 90 design
categories in their platform lets you
work directly with one designer that you
choose if you like their stuff which is
what I did for the Tao Seneca or you can
get concepts from multiple
designers and then pick your favorite so
whether you're starting a business or
just looking for extra design help
resources etc
99designs has a solution right now you
guys my listeners can receive a free $99
upgrade on your first design to check
out your first free upgrade please visit
99 designs comm forward slash Tim and
click the link on the landing page you
can also find their samples of projects
from you guys listeners who have used
9mn designs for logos apps even product
packaging so check it out 99 designs
dot-com forward slash Tim
you